foreign
[Music]
judge is being hunted by the people he's
sentenced to prison we're not using his
name for his safety
when the taliban took over afghanistan
it released thousands of inmates
including those from the country's
biggest and most notorious prison this
footage from a pro-taliban news agency
appears to show fighters letting inmates
out of the pulitzer key prison
videos like this started circulating
these men say they are from the pulitzer
key prison and are threatening to kill
the judges who put them there
there are many more judges who are in
hiding
my family is hiding with me they are in
the worst situation
than me because they always live in fear
the judges say they've also been
receiving threats from the taliban
despite the leadership announcing an
amnesty for afghans who had worked with
the u.s and the western back government
[Music]
it was
but human rights watch says that promise
has not been kept a november report says
taliban forces have executed or forcibly
disappeared more than 100 former police
and intelligence officers since taking
over the country
the international bar association has
raised concerns for the personal safety
and professional well-being of afghan
judges especially the 250 women judges
in that jurisdiction
zara which is not her real name is one
of them
um
[Music]
the judges now rely on close friends and
relatives for food and basic necessities
they change their hideouts often
i cannot even think about
my life i cannot do anything because
even i cannot go out to buy something
in a statement to bloomberg a taliban
spokesman said
we have declared amnesty to all and thus
there's no threat from us to the judges
but there could be some cases that might
have included a threat to the judges
which are preventable
he also said that 69 taliban members
have been appointed as new judicial
department heads 85 of the judicial
staff from the previous government
remains he added the judicial heads are
corruption free and experienced
professionals
[Music]
[Music]
people
[Music]